को नमस्कार आप सभी का स्वागत है जर्मन
सीखिए हिंदी में के 10 वें एपिसोड में आज
हम सीखेंगे सिंपल पास्ट टेंस इन जर्मन
जिसे जर्मन में कहते हैं प्रिटी पर वहां
जाने से पहले मुझे आशा है कि आप सभी ने
पहले 9 एपिसोड देखे होंगी
हैं और बहुत इंपोर्टेंट है क्योंकि मैं
जैसे क्लास में जिस ऑर्डर में सीखा था वह
उसी ऑर्डर में मैंने वह एपिसोड्स बनाए हुए
हैं और वह आर्डर इंपोर्टेंट है कि कुछ
कंसेप्ट डिफरेंट होते हैं पिछले कल सकते
मतलब फॉर एग्जांपल आज जो हम सीखने वाले
हैं उसके लिए आप का फोर्थ जो एपिसोड है
उसमें जो आवन-जावन कंसेप्ट है और सिर्फ जो
एपिसोड है उसमें जो मॉडल भर कंसेप्ट है वह
कंसेप्ट जानना जरूरी है कि जिले में सब आप
सब से विनती करूंगा कि आप लोग जिस इससे
पहले कि आगे के एपिसोड देखें पहले वह 9
एपिसोड देखकर कंप्लीट करें आपके कुछ भी
डाउट से तो वहां पर कमेंट का पूछ सकते हैं
ओके और इन एपिसोड 3 इंग अगर अभी आपको
चाहिए तो इस अपने एपिसोड के डिस्क्रिप्शन
लिंक मैं आपको मिलेगी सब की लिंक या फिर
आप मेरे चैनल पर जा सकते हैं वहां पर प्ले
लिस्ट में अपनी प्लेलिस्ट ले लो तो आपको
सारे वीडियो देख साथ मिल जाएंगे या इस
वीडियो
फ्रेंड में भी आपको प्लेलिस्ट का बटन मिल
जाए तो मेरी आपसे विनती है कि सबसे पहले
आप वह 9 वीडियोस देखिए और फिर हम यह शुरू
कर सकते हैं तो अगर आपने वह नए वीडियोस
देखते हैं तो अभियान शुरू करते हैं प्रिटी
भेजो
है जो सिंपल पास्ट टेंस है यह चार्ट्स में
सीखिए कितने चार प्लेलिस्ट पहली टिप पर
हमने क्या बोला था किसी भी भाषा में सबसे
इंपोर्टेंट वर्क दो कौन से हैं हवन और
जाएंगे तो भी * है हम पहले इनका पास ट्रेन
से कीजिए
कि हवन का पेस्ट कर सकता है अटल और संयम
का पार्ट होता है वहीं पर पास लिंक यह
अच्छी बात है कि वर्क जितना भी प्रेजेंट
टेंस में डेंजर इसलिए करें वह जब पास में
आता है तो बहुत ही से भी हेल्प करता है
एक्सांपल देता हूं अगर आपको याद हो
जायेंगे इसे भी हम करता है इस बिंदु बेस्ट
एनसीसी इस ईयर्स इन पर अपडेट्स नो लॉजिक
इन है पर वही ज्वाइन जब वारेंट बनेगा तो
कैसे चलेगा पर सबसे पहले हम देखेंगे अ ढंग
हटन कैसे चलता है अब देखते हैं इस खटल दूर
हट टेस्ट रेंज से हट यह टेस्ट वीर विशिष्ट
सिंपल सेट आई है अवनी इस खटल अपील हुई है
बटन मशरूम किए हैं
कि इस सवार दो युवक रविवार व्यवहार
व्यवहार अंग्रेज़ी वायरल सिंपल स्टूडेंट
स्टूडेंट वे स्टूडेंट्स वास बोर्न इन
सिंपल वे
जो कुछ भी इस में कठिनाई नहीं है पर मैं
आपको इसको और थोड़ा सा बनाता हूं फिर से
ठीक से यह दोनों टेबल देखिए इसमें क्या
इंपोर्टेंट है मैं आपको दिखाता हूं देखिए
इस और इस और दोनों सेम है करेक्ट इसका
विवाह है एक अभी हुआ दूकान दोनों में
सिर्फ टेस्टी लगा है
कि दूकान दोनों में सिर्फ टेस्टी लगा है
और यह हेयर को दोनों में सिर्फ तीन लगा
वाइट हट एक और और जी दोनों में हमने उसका
इनफेक्टिव कंप्लीट किया है वार्ड में अपने
हेयर लगाया है हफ्ते में वृद्धि था इसीलिए
हमने उस प्रेसिडेंट लगाए अ कंप्लीट किया
फिर से देखिए इस और सेम है दून में STD
को शेयर में तीन और बीयर और धीमे एनी आती
है अब आप लोग मैं फिर फिर एक बार क्यों
बोल रहा हूं कि तो बहुत सिंपल है और अगर
आपको यह रूल समझ में आया यह जो रूल है जो
मैं आपको बता रहा हूं यह समझ में आया तो
आपको पास्ट टेंस में आपको एक भी टेबल नहीं
आप करना पड़ेगा इतना ही इंपोर्टेंट है फिर
से देखो इस और के लिए सेम इस और के लिए
सिमरु दुखों लगेगा ऐड्स पेशेंट को लगेगा
और बिल्कुल लगेगा कि यह सब अगर यह रूल
क्लियर है नहीं है तो एक मिनट प्रिवेंट
करके कि
और आगे का एकदम सिंपल
अच्छा ठीक है तो आपको वायरल और हटन समझ
में आया अभी हम सेकंड स्टेप जाते हैं
सेकंड स्टेप किया है सिंपल भर सिंपल
वर्ड्स मतलब क्या अभी तक हमको आता है
आईपीएल क्रिकेट आई विल प्ले क्रिकेट अभी
हम सीखेंगे आई प्लेट के यह प्लेट क्रिकेट
कैसे बनाना है यह हम अभी देखते हैं तो
उसके लिए तुम सिंपल चीज है आप क्या करो
अपना स्क्लर्न प्ले मतलब स्टूडेंट्स को अब
हम चलते हैं पिलर में से यह कोटा यह को
हटाया तो क्या रहेंगे जाण प्लीज करेक्ट
अभी उसको जब भी आपका सिंपल व वर्गो हो तो
उसको सिर्फ टीवी लगाना तो क्या बने का या
पीड़ित भी नीडल यह आपका इंच फॉर्म बन गया
इस संबंध में एसपी लीटर नेट से कि आपका
काम हो गया है अभी फिर से ऊपर और अगर आपको
याद है इस और खैर को पी
12 को पीछे टेस्ट हेयर को फील ठाट बीयर्स
पेंटल साइड में आपको टेबल दिखाएं
कुछ करने की जरूरत ही नहीं है आखिर कौन
फिर मतलब रुख इसका क्या होगा कॉक अप कोटी
लगाया बॉटल इसको आफ्टर ड्रॉप टेस्ट प्लेयर
ऑफ द ईयर फॉर किड्स वियर कॉटन सिंपल कुछ
भी नहीं कर रहा है आपको तो सिर्फ कुछ काम
को उठाने लगा कर इसको तैयार करना है बाद
में तो अपना रोहित टेक केयर कर लेगा
सिमिलरली होगा लेहमन के लिए लैब का लेंटर
बनाओ और फिर इसको चला इस लेंटर यह लैंटर्न
प्लेयर अभी यह 20 सेकंड स्टेप क्या बोला
मैंने जो रेगुलर वर्ग विशेष उनका सामना लो
पी लें और आखिरी लगाओ इस फॉर्म बन ओं ऊपर
अलार्म लगाओ अभी अगर आप देखोगे हिंदी में
जाना का पासवर्ड क्या होता है गया जाया
नहीं होता जानवर गए
को आपस में संबंध नहीं है वैसे ही इंग्लिश
में भिगो का पास्ट टेंस क्या होता है वह
एंड तो हमने कैसे याद रखें हमने जब याद
रखना जड़ में भी अनफॉर्चूनेटली व्यूअर्स
उनके लिए हमको यह याद रखना पड़ेगा ऐसे कुछ
वर्ष की लिस्ट मैंने आपको अभी स्क्रीन पर
आपको दिखाई देगी तो उन पर से कुछ
इंपोर्टेंट वर्धन दें अब हम देखते हैं फैल
रहा है यह हेल्प टू गो उसका पास्ट टेंस
कैसे होता है देखते हैं उस पर जो शुरू
होता है वह बहुत हैडिंग क्या होता है किंग
पड़ा करना अपने भी इजी क्या है अगर आपको
दिन जाता है तो फिर से ईश्वर रैंकिंग गंवा
दी को बींस यह गैंग वियर हिम्न सिंगिंग न
सिर्फ आपको टेबल समझने की जरूरत नहीं है
या फिर कौन है कमेंट का पार्ट्स इसको है
का काम तो सिर्फ काम याद रखना है इस
में काम होगा दूं काम क्लियर कोमल जी को
में है यह बनता पार्ट होता है क्लब शुरू
होता है काया आपको सिर्फ काम याद रखना है
इस और काफी रहेगा दुख वैस्टीज लगाऊंगा भी
4G को का बंधन सिंपल है न हां आपको थोड़े
से अवार्ड याद रखने पड़ेंगे पर वह तो हम
हर लैंग्वेज में करते हुए इंग्लिश में भी
आपको अगर यहां हो गोवेर्मेंट को ऑन कम के
इनकम यह सब याद किया था यह व्यक्ति
फ्रेंड्स अब हम जाएंगे फोर्थ चैट पर व है
पास्ट टेंस आफ मुड़ा हुआ अभी इस्ट पराग्वे
से पहले मैं आपसे विनती करूंगा कि मैं 10
के आपने जो एपिसोड 6 मोड ऑफ वर्क का वह
अपने कंपनी की समझ लिया है कि अदरवाइज
आपको बहुत हार्ड जाएगा कि आप यह मॉडल व
चालान नहीं दिखाने वाले बॉडी हमने सीखा है
हम सिर्फ हमलावर कब पास्ट टेंस देखने वाले
मतलब क्या आई कैन प्ले क्रिकेटर
घड़ी आता है हम सिर्फ उसका आई कुछ प्ले
क्रिकेट बनाना सीखेंगे क्लियर है तो चलिए
करते हैं शुरुआत
हूं तो आई कैन प्ले क्रिकेट और आईपीएल
क्रिकेट में चेंज क्या हुआ इंग्लिश सिर्फ
यह कुछ हुआ वैसे ही हमको क्या करना है
जर्मन में यह जो कॉर्नर है जोनाथन है इनके
पास टेंस वाले रूप देखने तो चलिए आइए
देखते हैं कि उनका पास्ट टेंस होता है कौन
इन दोनों का पास्ट टेंस होता है जो पॉइंट
है यह पॉइंट का होता है दुर्ग दुर्ग तहत
मिशन का होता है मुट मुट और वजन का होता
है वर्ल्ड टर्न ऑन कर दो
कुछ समझ में आया सबको अभी देखो यह तो हमने
बना है अगर आपने देखा होगा हमने जब डालकर
कन्ज्यूगेट किए तो इतना बड़ा टेबल बना था
वैसे ही इसका भी यह टेबल करने का यह वड़ा
टैबलेट पर आगे आपको अगर रूल याद है तो यह
टेबल ऑफ़ को देखने की भी जरूरत नहीं आपको
सिर्फ 5 सेंटेंस याद रखना है 25 वर्ड याद
रख हैं कौन-कौन से कौन टल कॉन्टर जॉइन
अधेड़ तप मुस्तफा वांट टो
में एक बार आपने 5 मिनट याद रख लीजिए तो
आपको फिर से अपना वही रूम लगाना है एक बार
तो इस पड़ता है तो एपी कॉन्टेंट है दूं को
टेस्टी लगाओ दो कांटेस्ट एयर क्वालिटी
लगाओ यह पौन टेस्ट ड्रॉ निकाले राइड अगर
जो लंका है तो इशू पर जॉइंट अ हेयर क्या
होगा फिर जोड़कर दुख होगा धो लें और यह
छोटे भी अधीन डॉक्टर एकदम सिंपल एंड सिर्फ
5 करोड़ सीखने हैं यह थोड़े सेंटेंस बनाते
क्रिकेट खेलते हैं इस कॉन्टैक्ट नो
कि दूकान टेस्ट क्रिकेट पीले रंग एग
कांटेक्ट क्रिकेट क्लब हम सब क्रिकेट खेल
सकते थे क्वांटम क्रिकेट स्पीड देखिए
लिक्विड जिंक विलेन है
ए सिमिलर नेम बना सकते हैं शोल्डर क्रिकेट
पिलर यार इस ग्रुप क्रिकेट प्लेयर सबको
कुछ नहीं जो हम नार्मल मोड वर्ग के लिए कर
रहे थे आई कैन रिप्लिकेट अगर इसका
अतिरिक्त स्पिनर है आई कैन कोट इश्क
अंतरिक्ष पीने आपने क्या किया पीएम को एंड
में ले गए काम को चलाया है सिमिलरली
एक्जेक्टली सेम रहेगा आईटी एंड में ही
जाएगा काम की जगह कौन टरकाया इस कांटेस्ट
क्रिकेट प्लेयर सबको
136 बाद मैं आपको बताना चाहूंगा कि आपको
लगेगा कि वो डालकर तो जनरली किसी चीज की
पॉसिबली दिखाने के लिए यूज किए जाते हैं
तो उनका पास्ट टेंस क्यों यूज करते हैं तो
वह किसलिए तो कभी हम बोलते हैं अरे यार
मैं क्रिकेट खेल सकता था अरे यार मैं
क्रिकेट खेलना चाहता था तो ही इन जैसी
कंडीशन में हम यह मूड आलू अरविंद पास्ट
टेंस यूज करते हैं और उसके लिए तो क्या
सीखना है कुछ नहीं अगर कि वो डालकर क्लियर
है तो आपको 5 से पांच नए व्हाट्सएप में
हैं कांटेक्ट अदर गुप्ता मुकुट अप एंड
आफ्टर थे यह सब कम चलो तो अभी हम फिर से
कंप्लीट रिवीजन करते हैं चारों पॉइंट्स
होगी पहला पॉइंट हमने क्या सीखा वायरल हटल
सिंपल कुछ भी नहीं आई वह स्टूडेंट इस
वास्तु है आर्म होल डिश अटल राउडी दूसरा
पॉइंट हमने सीखा चक्र नॉर्मल और वैस्टीज
लंच पीछे उसका मेन स्टांप रोटी
टॉप पिंटो को इस रूप बना और फिर उसको अपने
रोल के हिसाब से चला थर्ड पॉइंट हमने देखा
देर आर्यन वैद्य और यह जो कुछ सुनते नहीं
तो उनके लिए क्या करना है आपको सिर्फ तुम
का इशू कि याद रखना है यह का गीत याद रखना
है कमेंट का काम याद रखना है और गयाविन का
दबाव याद रखना है फिर और चौथा हमने देखा
वो डॉल वर्क्स पार्ट्स में ही नॉर्मल में
डालकर जैसे ही चलते हैं आपको सिर्फ कि
उनकी जगह कांटेक्ट कर लूट है अगर 5 वर्ष
सीखने हैं कांटेक्ट डॉक्टर दुर्ग प्रमुख
सचिव पॉइंट और इन चारों के लिए एक ही कॉमन
रूम जो आपने सीखा सबसे इंपोर्टेंट रोल वह
क्या है तो वह है कि अगर इस और हेयर है तो
इश्क वाला ही रूम दूर है तो एसटीडी
कि यह छोटी और बीएफ और भी को यह इतना अगर
आपको याद है तो पास्ड इन बनाना एकदम अक्सर
ने मुझे आशा है कि आप सभी को प्रिंटेड
लड्डू यानि जर्मन सिंपल पास्ट टेंस एकदम
अच्छी तरह से समझ में आया होगा मैं आपसे
फिर से रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं कि आप नहीं अगर
सारे वीडियोस अगर पहले नहीं देखे हो तो
फिर एक बार देख लीजिए यह वीडियो में जब तक
आपको समझ में आए तब तक देख लीजिए कोई भी
आपके डाईट सवा तो कमेंट सेक्शन में लिखिए
मैं उनके आंसर देने की पूरी कोशिश करो
तो फिर मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में
धन्यवाद